hoy quiero hablarles de resiliencia
quiero hablarles de comunidades quiero
hablarles de identidad quiero hablarles
de cómo estos tres conceptos en su
intersección son fundamentales cuando
nos planteamos cómo vamos a responder
cómo vamos a recuperarnos y cómo vamos a
ser resilientes con capacidad de
adaptación frente a los desafíos que el
mundo enfrenta en el día de hoy vamos a
detenernos primero en este mapa que
tenemos aquí
indonesia hace unos días todos sabemos
que indonesia la isla de sulawesi fue
ampliamente afectada por un terremoto y
un tsunami
unos años atrás todos recordarán también
todos y todos recordarán en 2004 un
tremendo terremoto en la costa
occidental de la isla de sumatra en
indonesia 9.1 en la escala de richter
uno de los cuatro grandes terremotos del
siglo 2021 una devastación monumental
generó una ola un tsunami de hasta 600
kilómetros de velocidad que azotó la
costa de 14 países en este océano en
esta bahía en el medio de esa
devastación cuáles fueron los resultados
280 mil muertes 2.5 millones de personas
afectadas por esta crisis devastación
miseria humana sin dudas
y en el medio de este caos de este de
esta destrucción tenemos esta isla una
isla llamada centinela del norte una
isla que pertenece a un archipiélago el
archipiélago de andamán en la bahía de
bengala entre la india e indonesia una
isla que luce así
muy bella con una prístina playa
alrededor
rodeada de una barrera de recife que la
mantienen inaccesible diez meses de los
doce meses del año pero qué tiene de
particular esta isla ustedes se
preguntarán por qué estamos hablando de
esta isla en el marco de un tsunami pues
es una de las pocas
islas o uno de los pocos sitios en el
mundo que perduran aislados de la
civilización tal y como la conocemos los
sentineleses se habla de que son entre
40 y 500 nadie lo sabe con certeza han
estado por siglos aislados de toda la
civilización y contacto humano es una
una isla que retrocede en el pasado y
que nos hace pensar cómo reaccionó ante
este fenómeno es una isla con estatus
protegido por el gobierno de la india y
que desde 1880 no hay registros de
contacto con sociedades humanas en el
medio del caos provocado por el tsunami
el gobierno indio demoró varios días en
enviar una flota y una misión
exploratoria a observar cómo habían
atravesado por esta gran crisis los anti
ingleses
la idea era que con una devastación tan
grande en zonas tan cercanas los
sentineleses seguramente no habían
podido sobrevivir el nivel de impacto
que había tenido el tsunami
bueno pues resulta que cuando el
helicóptero sobrevuela la isla
interesantemente se encontraron con la
misma respuesta que habían encontrado
una y otra vez insultos piedras flechas
los sentineleses estaban allí habían
sobrevivido perfectamente y
aparentemente estaban muy sanos como se
explica qué fue lo que pasó pues aquí lo
que estamos viendo es como pueblos
nativos a través de las generaciones y a
través de la memoria y la transmisión
oral transmitieron el conocimiento
necesario para sobrevivir a terremotos y
tsunamis de la manera en que lo hicieron
estos sentineleses vamos a mirar otro
ejemplo vamos a otro lugar remoto mucho
más en altura a 5000 metros de altura y
por cierto desértico el desierto de
atacama
en el sur de américa en chile el
desierto de atacama fue por buena parte
del siglo 19 y por buena parte del siglo
20 también la cuna del salitre del mundo
el salitre utilizado como fertilizante
por mucho tiempo en los países europeos
que en su momento estaban en un boom de
explosión poblacional de crecimiento y
chile fue sin dudas el gran exportador
de salitre por muchas décadas 80% de las
exportaciones llegaron de los ingresos
de las exportaciones llegaron a provenir
del salitre esto generó un boom
fenomenal lo llamaban el oro blanco
como todas que tienen los commodities
también tienen su caída y que le pasó
atacama pues los pueblos del salitre de
atacama por muchas décadas con la caída
de la venta del salitre cayeron en la
sombra y quedaron por décadas detenidos
en el tiempo pero atacama al igual que
centinela encontró formas de
reinventarse hace unos años quienes lo
hayan escuchado tal vez conocen en esta
planicie en chajnantor la planicie donde
ven estos telescopios es donde muchos
países unidos han generado un excelente
proyecto para la observación astronómica
del estudio de las estrellas y del
origen del universo atacama a través de
la ciencia reinventa su espacio y su
identidad y genera un nuevo paradigma
los atacameños chajnantor esta planicie
que ustedes ven aquí es una planicie
árida a 5000 metros de altura con las
condiciones ideales para recibir las
ondas cósmicas que nos permiten ver las
estrellas y estudiarlas de manera
fehaciente en la lengua atacameña en el
origen jan tore significa sitio de
lanzamiento que nos indica esto que ya
por las generaciones y los siglos de los
siglos los nativos atacameños utilizado
en esta misma planicie para escudriñar
el firmamento vamos a otro sitio vamos a
ubicarnos ahora en otro desierto un
poquito más al norte en el estado de
nevada muchos de ustedes lo conocerán
las vegas' las venas fue una parada de
ferrocarril en el siglo 19 cuando llega
la ley
la legalización del juego en mil 931 se
convierte en un modesto centro de
apuestas luego en los años 50 en la
posguerra comienza a hacer el núcleo
para actividades mafiosas el hotel
flamingo nos retrotrae a ese contexto y
se convierte en una suerte de capital de
la reinvención y la resiliencia en los
eeuu una ciudad con capacidad de auto
generar su identidad de una manera
fenomenal y se convierte en esto en una
franja de tan solo 4 millas en el centro
mundial del entretenimiento en una
propuesta vinculada al destino turístico
para lunas de miel para el matrimonio
entretenimiento al estilo disney en el
2008 ustedes recordarán tuvimos la gran
recesión que afectó sin dudas a los eeuu
que fue donde comenzó
de manera muy puntual afectó a una
ciudad como las vegas' la caída de los
precios inmobiliarios fue rotunda 15 por
ciento de desempleo doble dígito de
desempleo en un país industrializado un
país desarrollado como eeuu era
realmente inverosímil fuerte caída de
los ingresos en general para la ciudad
de hasta el 15% pero empecinada en
reinventarse esta ciudad logró rebotar y
reinventarse hoy las vegas' se sigue
expandiendo tiene récord de visitación y
es una capital culinaria en el mundo con
al menos 25 restaurantes con estrellas
michelín
de qué nos habla todo esto nos da una
perspectiva sobre la noción de
resiliencia de qué hablamos cuando
hablamos de resiliencia qué concepto
estamos pensando latín la tiene el latín
resiliente residió quiere decir rebotar
volver hacia atrás en la acepción más
general
elasticidad
en la física en la ingeniería se trata
de esto se trata de la capacidad de un
cuerpo de retornar a su forma de
recuperar su forma luego de estirarse de
manera elástica en ecología otro término
es la capacidad de un ecosistema de la
biosfera de a partir de su dinámica
interna poder recuperarse frente a un
choque externo por ejemplo un incendio
en psicología es la capacidad del ser
humano de recuperarse frente a
situaciones adversas pero lo que a mí
más me interesa compartir con ustedes es
como esto se traslada al fenómeno
comunitario como tomamos de todas estas
disciplinas que estudiaron el concepto
de resiliencia y cómo lo traemos a
comunidades y a sociedades pues de lo
que se trata es
de ver como la naturaleza humana tiene
no sólo la capacidad de enfrentar la
adversidad sino de prepararse para esas
adversidades enfrentarlas
a los crisis y las choques y sobre todo
recuperarse frente a estas cuáles son
los grandes desafíos de resiliencia que
tenemos hoy día porque estamos hablando
de resiliencia cuando hablamos de los
grandes fenómenos de desarrollo a nivel
mundial porque tenemos que pensar en
resiliencia pues porque no nos queda
mucho tiempo porque tenemos desafíos muy
grandes que atender de hecho como lo
vemos aquí si nosotros pensamos en los
grandes impactos a nivel mundial y en
los grandes tendencias de desarrollo
sabemos que estamos alcanzando límites
planetarios que es un límite planetario
es aquel umbral que una vez que la
humanidad lo atraviese no será posible
tener vida humana sobre el planeta
tierra
si seguimos produciendo y consumiendo a
los niveles en que lo estamos haciendo
en 2018 para el año 2050 vamos a
necesitar dos planetas y medio para
poder regenerar la capacidad natural de
la tierra de regenerar sus ecosistemas y
sus recursos naturales hoy somos 7000
millones de personas en 2050 seremos
dos tercios de esos nueve mil millones
seis mil quinientos millones de personas
van a vivir en ciudades se imaginen
imaginen la explosión creativa que eso
significa imaginen también
las presiones sobre los recursos y los
sistemas da miedo verdad pues si las
ciudades están atrapadas en tormentas
perfectas tenemos degradación ambiental
tenemos erosión de recursos tenemos
capas que se complican con patrones de
pobreza de desigualdad sistemas de
gobernanza de eficientes necesitamos
respuestas y ahí es donde desde las
naciones unidas donde trabajo pero
también con muchos otros actores
comunidades como ustedes
sistemas organizacionales pero sobre
todo los regímenes multilaterales vienen
a dar algunas respuestas los objetivos
de desarrollo sostenible en particular
el número 11 que habla de cómo debemos
ordenar ciudades y comunidades para
obtener resiliencia y obtener
sostenibilidad y sobre todo los marcos
de los regímenes multilaterales que nos
ayudan a pensar y a poner en foco este
tema el acuerdo de parís por poner un
ejemplo en cambio climático' el marco de
sendai sobre la gestión de riesgo de
desastres la nueva agenda urbana todos
estos temas no se están poniendo en foco
la necesidad de pensar en comunidad de
pensar en resiliencia y unir las
respuestas para su foco turismo y
comunidad estos son dos temas que van
muy de la mano toda la experiencia de un
turista tiene que ver con lo local y
tiene que ver con conocer comunidades de
manera muy cercana
estamos en puntacana y este es un
excelente ejemplo de comunidad turística
de destino turístico el turismo es uno
de los sectores que más crecen a nivel
mundial
de cada once empleos a nivel mundial se
generan en este sector 10% del pib
mundial se genera en este sector fuente
fuerte empleador de mujeres fuerte
empleador de jóvenes y sobre todo
fuertísimo creador de eslabonamiento
productivo por cada empleo que se genera
en el sector turístico se genera un
empleo y medio en la cadena productiva
república dominicana no es ajena a esta
tendencia de república dominica en el 15
por ciento de los empleos se generan en
el sector productivo 5% del pib en el
sector de forma directa y 15 de forma
indirecta 40% de las divisas de este
país se originan en este sector qué
oportunidades tenemos acá para escapar
este tipo de realidades cuáles son los
desafíos que tenemos para generar
sistemas turísticos sistemas de
respuestas resilientes frente a las
crisis que nos acechan sin dudas los
desafíos son muchos y república
dominicana- como un estado insular en
desarrollo donde se conjugan amenazas y
vulnerabilidades tiene muchos desafíos
por delante
pero la gestión de las crisis será
fundamental a la hora de reflexionar
cómo vamos a avanzar para dar las
respuestas en este sentido será que los
sistemas turísticos tienen mucha
capacidad de carga
hay exceso agotamiento de algunos
modelos tenemos tal vez shocks
sistémicos por ejemplo erosión de playas
sin dudas todos estos temas nos traen a
pensar que tenemos que reflexionar como
sociedad que tenemos que reflexionar
como comunidad cuáles van a ser nuestros
resortes para generar la resiliencia
necesaria y no tener este tipo de
resultados luego de que los choques
lleguen porque créanme que los choques
van a llegar van a seguir viniendo y
serán cada vez más intensos y cada vez
más severos
pensemos por un momento en algún ejemplo
del mundo verdad hay muchas comunidades
en el planeta tierra que han generado
patrones de resiliencia y comunidades
identificadas con el tema turístico
veamos el momento por un momentito el
caso español españa es uno de los casos
simbólicos de productos turísticos
vinculados al sol y playa es uno de esos
modelos que de hecho se sesgo muy
fuertemente hasta s hasta hasta hace
poco tiempo en productos muy vinculados
a la oferta natural ahora nosotros
sabemos y la teoría lo indica que estos
modelos alcanzan un punto de expansión y
un punto de agotamiento necesitamos
pensar cuando hablamos de resiliencia en
modelos complementarios donde están
aquellos elementos aquellos elementos
por ejemplo del patrimonio cultural de
la diversidad geográfica que podemos
incorporar en modelos como sol y playa y
esto por supuesto resuena muy
fuertemente para república dominicana
como fue
destino turístico que puede explotar
esto por cierto cuando hablamos de
comunidades resilientes y comunidades
sostenibles no podemos dejar de pensar
en toda esta gama de dimensiones no
podemos dejar de pensar en que los
sistemas de gobernanza los sistemas de
gestión pública tienen que ir de la mano
de cómo posicionamos la proyección
internacional la movilidad de transporte
el capital humano se trata de generar
sociedades como decíamos antes que
puedan prepararse que puedan enfrentar
la adversidad del choque y que puedan
recuperarse de dicho choque quien ese
rebotar se puede aparejar y dar de nuevo
en centinela del norte los sentineleses
en realizaron su resiliencia en el
conocimiento tradicional en atacama fue
jalado por la ciencia en las vegas'
vimos que fue modelado a través de su
esquema de negocios si lo hacemos bien a
la república dominicana el cielo puede
ser el límite de muchas gracias
[Aplausos]